Der ebola ausbruch
im kongo erreicht eine neue entscheidende phase der worst case ist jetzt bereits geschehen schon kurz nach dem
Ausbruch hat die solche bereits eine millionenstadt erreicht was vor wenigen tagen
Noch befürchtet wurde ist jetzt schon, eingetreten der erste infizierte ist jetzt
Im wan dakar aufgetaucht damit bekommt die solche eine deutlich schnellere dynamik als noch vor vier
Jahren als sich wochenlang auf dem land diese solche hielt was sind jetzt die folgen im kongo was macht die weltgesundheitsorganisation
Und geht jetzt alles viel schneller als noch vor einigen. Jahren in westafrika
krieg zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Heute hier vom swr aus mainz der worst case ist eingetreten und das viel schneller als befürchtet
Zwar gibt es nur ein paar infiziert dem. Kongo aber davon sind einige pflege
Also personal das die solche an ganz viele kontaktpersonen verbreiten kann auf dem land halten
Sich die kontakte ja meistens in grenzen aber in der stadt sind einer solchen solche kaum grenzen gesetzt
Und damit ist jetzt schon, ein einer sehr frühen phase der schlimmste fall eingetreten
ein infizierter wurde in der millionenstadt man dakar entdeckt vom ausbruch in westafrika wissen wir ja wie
Entscheidend einzelpersonen sein können und dann zum super verbreiter werden können
Und genau das kann jetzt hier geschehen sein die stadt mit rund 1,2 millionen einwohnern bietet. Dabei den. Idealen. Nährboden
Um, eine solche schnell zu verbreiten es gibt kaum elektrizität
Und auch nur wenig sauberes wasser die stadt liegt am ufer des kongo flusses mit waren, und personenverkehr in die hauptstadt
Kinshasa die menschen sind hier mobil und können den erreger innerhalb von nur wenigen stunden anders als im ländlichen raum im ganzen kongo verbreiten
Mit dem infizierten hat die solche laut weltgesundheitsorganisation who eine neue phase erreicht die
Neuen zahlen sprechen von 42 infiziert von 23 toten die
Kontaktpersonen werden auf 500 bis 4000 geschätzt zitat mit dem fall in baden
Ist die situation äußerst ernst. Und besorgniserregend geworden da die krankheit erstmals. Eine stadt erreicht hat
So henry gray von ärzte. Ohne grenzen ebner ist. Ein fieber das in rund der hälfte der fälle zum tod
Führt das beginnt relativ harmlos wie eine grippe aber im weiteren verlauf fangen die opfer an überall zu bluten und sterben schließlich
an multiplem organversagen
übertragen wird die krankheit meistens von sogenannten reservoir würden das sind wildtiere die gejagt
Und gegessen werden durch die abholzung von wäldern rücken menschen immer näher an diese populationen. Heran
Und jagen dann flughunde affen oder zum, beispiel stachelschweine und dieses buschfleisch. Führt. Dann meistens zum
Ausbruch der seuche im gegensatz zum. Ausbruch 2014 ist die weltgesundheitsorganisation
aber dieses mal deutlich schneller in aktion getreten
Generaldirektors debré jesus ist bereits vor ort und 4000 dosen des
Über den berichtet hatten mit dem kontaktpersonen geimpft werden sollen die sind auch bereits
Im kongo trotzdem ist der region man muss sagen in panik in nigeria soll. Ein für den
28 mai geplantes fußball spiel der nationalmannschaft. Gegen die nationalmannschaft des kongo abgesagt werden
Ein solches großereignis mit nur einem infizierten könnte eine katastrophe auslösen, man ist also extrem vorsichtig
Und aber auch sehr gut vorbereitet doch eines ist dieses mal anders. So früh
Wurde die solche noch nie in eine millionenstadt getragen ich hatte. Euch ja versprochen
Euch auf dem laufenden zu halten das mache ich auch weiterhin. Ihr wisst ja dass das abo modell auf youtube nicht
So richtig funktioniert deshalb wenn
Ihr also nichts vom ebola ausbruch zum thema verpassen wollt und als erster informiert werden wollt dann endet
meine telefonnummer whatsapp und den anderen messengern dann erfahrt
Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich, um garantiert einfach hier draufklicken. Und zur begrüßung habe ich auch noch
Ein kleines goodie. Und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Glocke vergessen. Und zur sicherheit hier geht es war damit. Dafür auch. Darauf klicken neuer ausbruch mit der vorgeschichte dieses ausbruchs ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt dran